ah j'ai peur pour mes enfants j'ai peur
pour mes enfants
i am friend for my sheer
il a fait parler lui moumoundir on
évoquant la polémique autour de la
bagarre dans une interview vous avez
même interpellé Emmanuel Macron Emmanuel
Macron le président regarde vous pouviez
lui parler là les yeux dans les yeux
monsieur Macron vous déconnez il va
falloir vous reprendre très vite par
rapport à quoi
il faut laisser les Français de
confession musulmane tranquille il faut
pas que notre pays la France se trompe
dans son histoire et trahit son histoire
et ses valeurs il faut que ça soit
focale reste une république démocratique
et populaire et pas qu'une république et
pour vous aujourd'hui Moundir ce n'est
plus le cas moi pour l'instant en tout
cas de ce que je vois j'ai peur pour mes
enfants on est là on sait que les
problèmes qui a qui sont qui sont
abominables dans le service de l'école
pas de prof pas de sport les
établissements c'est une catastrophe et
la seule chose qu'on
qu'on nous matraque c'est des filles qui
portent une robe longue avec des bras
longs et on leur dit vous allez pas vous
allez pas aller à l'école ok génial quoi
donc c'est tout ça il y a que ça qu'on
retient quoi
même si c'est un ami vous pouvez le
défoncer ou pas bien entendu voilà non
non non à la gilbertez oui
bon tu es dans la merde tu as Gilles
Verdez avec toi mon Moundir on va les
laisser te répondre Jacky Jacky
[Rires]
non mais
tu mélanges un peu tout je t'écoute tu
développes bah tu dis laisser les
musulmans tranquille les Français de
musulman les Français de confession
musulmane tranquille oui mais bien sûr
ça n'a aucun rapport bah développe la
Baya non mais on en a déjà beaucoup
parlé la semaine dernière moi je
considère que c'est ce positionnement
systématique qui consiste à dire arrêter
de vous en prendre aux musulmans c'est
une tromperie intellectuelle parce que
on il y a un règlement qui a été édicté
et on te demande on te demande juste en
fait à ce que
le principe de la laïcité soit respecté
de A à Z et ça n'est pas dirigé contre
les musulmans ni contre une autre
religion voilà
moi pour moi en fait tu es en train de
te fourvoyer en fait tu te trompes en
fait parce qu'en fait moi je pense qu'il
faut pas que tes peurs pour tes enfants
il faut que tu sois soulagé pour tes
enfants merci parce qu'en fait c'est une
chance que en France ce que tu parles de
l'école la République la X c'est vrai
que c'est un peu brouillon voilà on a la
chance que notre école soit un
sanctuaire et quand tu arrives dans une
école aujourd'hui en France on doit pas
savoir quelle est ta religion la
religion reste à la maison la religion
elle est intime elle est privée et peu
importe ta religion peu importe ta foi
si tu crois si tu crois pas et donc
c'est une chance donc c'est une chance
pour tes enfants en fait qui puissent
arriver à l'école
voilà ils sont juste des citoyens en
devenir et ils vont apprendre à l'école
plein de choses sur l'histoire sur
l'évolution sur sur les rapports entre
les hommes et les femmes et tout ça tout
ça c'est possible à l'école dans ce
sanctuaire de l'école et donc ça sert à
rien d'avoir peur pour tes enfants parce
qu'ils ont de la chance de vivre en
France tu as de la chance de vivre en
France et ça sert à rien à mon avis de
d'interpeller Emmanuel Macron et là bah
il y a c'est très bien qu'elle reste
hors de l'école et d'ailleurs ça a été
validé par le Conseil d'État non moi
j'ai juste une question à me dire c'est
que moi j'ai envie de croire naïvement
tout ce qu'on me raconte et quand on me
dit que la Baya c'est c'est ça aucun
rapport avec la confession musulmane et
quand on t'entends toi parler et que tu
dis qu'il faut qu'on lâche les Français
de confession musulmane du coup j'ai
envie de prendre le rapport c'est une
question très naïve et je veux vraiment
savoir
nul n'est plus sourds qui ne va entendre
alors
bien évidemment lorsque je alors je ne
fustige pas le le Président je réponds à
une question de justement de Jordan qui
me demande de luxe de luxe absolument et
lorsque je dis effectivement qu'il faut
cesser d'embêter les Français de
confession musulmane pour la simple et
bonne raison et je rajoute à cela quand
je dis que j'ai peur pour mes enfants
j'ai peur pour mes enfants pas forcément
que pour la à Baya parce que ma fille de
7 ans m'a posé la question papa c'est
quoi une abaya j'ai aussi peur pour mes
enfants lorsqu'il y a des actes
terroristes j'ai aussi peur de mes
enfants lorsqu'on met des drogués à côté
des écoles j'ai aussi peur pour mes
enfants pour qu'il arrive je suis un
papa et donc je m'inquiète néanmoins et
je reviens mais là vous dites tu es
interrogé sur la Bayonne non non
il m'a pas il m'a pas dit est-ce que
vous êtes contre la Baya j'ai pas dit ça
moi pour moi ce qui est islamique c'est
le voile le voile il y a une règle c'est
on le retire on le met pas à l'école on
le retire il y a une loi moi la laïcité
je la respecte parfaitement d'accord
en 86 en 86 j'ai fait mes études au
lycée Pasteur à Oran devrait s'inquiéter
pour tes enfants c'est ça que non mais
moi je suis papa et je m'inquiète de ce
qui se voit donc en tant que Français
fier de l'être et de confession
musulmane je te le dis et je veux pas
être plus clair aujourd'hui parce qu'on
est en direct le voile ne rentre pas
dans l'école est-ce que c'est clair oui
ou non très bien très bien là-bas il y a
pour moi et je le confirme n'est pas
islamique alors pourquoi néanmoins si
maintenant le le Conseil d'État a validé
j'étais pas au courant qu'ils avaient
été donc il avait été et ben il rentre
pas et puis voilà donc voilà donc
maintenant moi je reviens parce que j'ai
reçu quelques petits messages bon les 60
millions de Français tu reçois à 8
messages peut-être de du côté de
l'extrême droite moi j'en ai reçu
beaucoup plus du côté de gens qui me
traitaient de racisme islamophobe et
tout ça mais moi ça me dérange pas mais
moi ça me dérange moi ça me dérange
aujourd'hui que quand on est contre la
Baïa à l'école on sera traité de racisme
et moi je viens de recevoir un message
est-ce que tu vends ta voiture
j'en ai pas fait des caisses donc oui je
trouve que c'est dramatique en fait en
terme de laïcité j'ai un père qui
s'appelle un beau-père pardon qui
s'appelle David j'ai ma tante qui
s'appelle Nicole ma grand-mère
s'appelait Catherine Garcia et j'ai des
cousins qui s'appelle Franck et Cédric
et mon père en termes de laïcité et des
gens du Livre père il fait des
confitures aussi non mais c'est vrai
aussi et en plus de ça ayant fait des
études en Algérie en Algérie en 86 au
lycée Pasteur à Oran ou l'internat était
français ben moi j'ai appris dans cette
école où il y a des gens qui venaient
avec la kippa il y avait des Roumains il
y avait des Américains il y avait des
personnes qui portaient moins ou non
attendez excuse-moi
et donc voilà maintenant s'il y a une
loi qui dit il faut l'enlever il faut
l'enlever et ça s'arrête là voilà je
peux pas être plus clair non mais s'il y
a une loi qui dit demain ils font
enlever Gilles Verdez je l'enlèverai ben
moi je le récupère
c'est hyper important parce que ta voix
forcément elle porte ça hein OK et le
fait de dire quelque part c'est contre
les musulmans ça veut dire qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens qui vont t'écouter et
qui vont suivre ce mouvement là alors et
moi je voudrais juste te poser une
question on l'a jamais dit dans nos
débats là on a tous suivi ce qui s'est
passé en Iran en Iran les choses là-bas
moi je dis pas que tu es de là-bas je
suis toujours du côté des opprimés donc
si tu vas voir pour le cas des femmes
j'allais te dire est-ce que tu as ces
discussions là avec les gens avec ta
famille alors il faudrait que tu vois ce
que je veux dire alors écoute c'est
hyper important parce que c'est dès que
j'ai mon beau-père qui s'appelle David
ma belle-mère s'appelle Frédéric je peux
pas je peux pas te dire autre que ma
femme c'est le symbole d'une soumission
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous pouvez pas nier Jacques c'est que
aujourd'hui
tous les musulmans tous les musulmans de
France d'accord tous les musulmans
discutent entre parent pourquoi est-ce
qu'on nous fait ça donc vous pouvez
parler
à partir du moment où on dit les
musulmans les Juifs les femmes les
Français on dit une connerie
non mais voilà quand on englobe et qu'on
essentialise une connerie parce qu'il y
a autant de d'avis qu'il y a de
musulmans il y a autant d'avis qu'il y a
de français
en tout cas il a raison de s'inquiéter
non à 80%. merci les chiens elon mus